[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى بانوراما يقدمها
لكم ابراهيم بدر وهذه ابرز عناوين
بواساطه عمانيه بوابه الرياض تفتح طريق
طهران نحو القاهره فهل استوعبت ايران
الدرس وهل ادركت ان اي انفتاح على دول
الجوار يجب ان يمر عبر البوابه السعوديه
بعد عقدين من الزمن لا زال الشتات البعث
قانونا تمر عبره الحسابات السياسيه فهل
يطوي العراق هذه الصفحه ام ان بعض الكتل
العراقيه مرتبطا ببقاء شبح البعث
[موسيقى]
التطورات تتسارع في مسار العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه التي تتجه نحو
الانفتاح على العالم العربي الهدف بعث
مرحله جديده تقوم على اساس حسن الجوار
وتوسيع مساحات التفاهم والبحث عن المصالح
الوطنيه والاستراتيجيه العلاقات العمانيه
الايرانيه الوثيقه تلعب دورا في هذا
التوجه وتحقيق التقارب المنشود مع دول
الجوار ضمن مساعي طهران لتحسين علاقاتها
مع السعوديه بعد سبع سنوات من القطيعه
والتي سترسم مشهد جيوس سياسي جديد في
المنطقه زياره سلطان عمان هيثم بن طارق
الاخيره الى طهران انتظرتها القياده
الايرانيه طويلا للبحث عن اليات جديده
تقوم على اعتماد الرؤيه العمانيه تجاه
اعاده احياء الاتفاق النووي وايضا سبل
احياء وتوطيد العلاقات الايرانيه مع
السعوديه ومصر وتهدئه الوضع الاقليمي
ايران استوعبت الدرس بخصوص البعد الجديد
في سياستها ذات الطبيعه الاقليميه وادركت
ان اي انفتاح على دول الجوار لن يكون
ممكنا ما لم يكن عبر البوابه السعوديه
وموقفها ورؤيتها للمصلحه الوطنيه والعربيه
والاقليميه بالتالي تحقيق التقرب معها
سيكون المفتاح الرئيسي في المرحله المقبله
حيث ان هذا الادراك للدوري السعودي في
المعادلات الاقليميه والعربيه لمسته
القياده الايرانيه من نتائج الاتفاق الذي
وقعته مع الرياض في شهر مارس الماضي هنا
طبعا تجدر الاشاره الى ان المسار السياسي
الملزم للدوله الايرانيه بضمان الامن
والاستقرار هو التحدي الاكبر لابراهيم
رئيسي حتى يتمكن من تاسيس مرحله جديده
مختلفه عن السابق
اتفاق استئناف العلاقات بين السعوديه
وايران اهم بنود الاتفاق احترام سياده
الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه
الموافقه على استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه اعاده فتح سفارتي البلدين
خلال مده اقصاها شهران تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني الموقعه في عام 2001 تفعيل
الاتفاقيه العامه للتعاون الموقعه في عام
1998 والتي تشمل قطاعات مهمه ابرزها
الاقتصاد والتجاره
ينضم الينا من بغداد حسن فحص الكاتب
الصحفي ومن طهران الدكتور محمد صالح
صديقان مدير المركز العربي للدراسات
الايرانيه اهلا بكما ضيفي العزيزين
واسمحالي ان ابدا مع ضيفي من بغداد حسن
فحص الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك سيد حسن بدايه
في كل هذه الزيارات وهذا النوع من
الزيارات هناك نوعان
ربما
مهمه معلنه ومهمه سريه اذا جازت تعبير
باعتقادكم ماذا حمل سلطان عمان للمرشد
الايراني وماذا سمع منه
اولا تحياتي لك استاذ ابراهيم ولضيف
الكريم الصديق
صدقيان
اعتقد ان زياره السلطان العماني الى طهران
زياره مفصليه وتاريخيه لان
قد تشكل التاسيس للمرحله الجديده من
علاقات ايران مع
المحيط العربي والجوار الخليجي وايضا في
العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والمجتمع الدولي فيما يتعلق من بوابه
الاتفاق النووي لذلك ما سمع من في طهران
من كلام للمرشد مع او متى هو سائل الاعلام
مع الضيف العماني
وجه رسائل واضحه وشفافه ايضا
على رغبه الطهران
والنظام بكل مؤسساته العميقه
على الانتقال الى مرحله جديده من بناء
الثقه في مع دول الجوار
وان
المرشد في اشارته الى الاتفاق
الايراني السعودي
يحاول ان يوجه رساله طمانه للقياده
السعوديه بانه يقف خلف هذا الاتفاق ولن
يسمح
بتاثير عليه سلبا او عرقلته
بالاضافه الى انه
شكل المدخل الرئيس
للانفتاح الايراني على العمق العربي او
المحيط العربي
واعاده ترميم علاقات متوتره مع
العديد من الدول العربيه التي استمرت
لاربعه عقود وان هذه المرحله مرحله جديده
بالنسبه له
في الظاهره اما في في الخفاء او ما لم
يعلن ان السلطان العماني ايضا مهتم ايضا
يعني تشكل القضيه اليمنيه محور اساسي في
اهتمامات عمان لانها معنيه بهذه الازمه
كما السعوديه وكما كل دول العربيه
والخليجيه لذلك
السلطان او المساعي العمانيه تريد اهم
تاكيد
الضمانات الايرانيه بجديه طهران في الدفع
باتجاه الحل في الازمه اليمنيه لذلك ايضا
هذه الزياره تاخذ طابعا يمنيا خاصه ايضا
دون الاعلان طيب دكتور صادق يامن طهران هل
وصلت طهران الى قناعه بان تطبيع علاقاتها
مع دول المنطقه لا ياتي الا من خلال
البوابه السعوديه وماذا التقطم ايضا او
ايضا من زياره سلطان عمان الى طهران
استاذ ابراهيم والى الزميل والصديق حسن
وللمشاهدين
ان يعتقد بان كل دول المنطقه يعني بعد
الازمه الاوكرانيه بعد جائحه كورونا وبعد
الازمه الاوكرانيه اعتقد بان جميع دول
المنطقه بادت مقتنعه بان طرق السلام
والتنميه والامن والاستقرار التكلفه من
طرق المواجهه والتدافع السياسي والانديه
الذي شهدته المنطقه خلال العقدين الماضيين
وبالتالي عندما
تمت الحوارات الجولات الخمسه من الحوار
بين طهران والرياض في بغداد كان هناك
قناعه بان يتجه الجانبان او البلدان الى
وضع قواعد جديده
ووضع قواعد للتفاهم جديده عندما تمت
المبادره الصينيه طرحت المبادره الصينيه
انا لا انفي وجود بعض التيارات ربما لا
تريد العلاقه مع السعوديه لاسباب كثيره
لكن بشكل عام حكومه الرئيس ابراهيم
الرئيسي يعني منذ اكثر من عام عندما فاز
الرئيس ابراهيم رئيس بالرئاسه الايرانيه
وهو اراد يعني هذه سياسه وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ايضا وحتى مجلس الامن القومي
الايراني ايضا هذه السياسه الرسميه
ارى بان هذا الاتفاق
ربما يسير بشكل بطيء لكن اعتقد بانه اذا
تم احتضانه
باطر امنيه وسياسيه اعتقد بانه نستطيع ان
نتفائل
لمستقبل العلاقات الايرانيه السعوديه
والايرانيه العربيه بشكل عام سيد حسن فحص
يعني هل تتفق مع رؤيه الدكتور صاد القيام
بان هذه التيارات بدات تقتنع بانه التقارب
مع دول المنطقه افضل ام انها كانت مجبره
ومن هي هذه التيارات
لا شك ان هذه التيارات وخاصه تيار
الثابتون او البيدري ها بالتعبير الايراني
قد لا ترضى عن هذا التحول وهي ما زالت
ترفع الصوت من انني لاخر عبر
منصاتها الاعلاميه ومواقف قياداتها
المشككه بجدوى هذا هذه هذا المسار الجديد
ولكن مصلحه النظام والدوله العميقه
والغرفه القرار الايراني ترى تنظر الى
المصلحه الاستراتيجيه والمصلحه
الاقتصاديه والمصلحه الامنيه
وكل يعني منظومه المصالح الايرانيه تنظر
لها بعين الاهتمام وعين الاعتبار يعني
ماذا ستخسر ماذا ستخسر هذه التيارات اذا
ما حدث تقارب بين ايران والسعوديه بشكل
رئيسي وبعد ذلك اتباعا مع باقي الدول وعلى
راسها مصر
حسابات هذه التيارات هي داخليه وليست
خارجيه ممكن اذا هي اذا وصلت الى الى
مواقع القرار ان تتخذ هذا المسار وتذهب به
بعيدا ولكن طالما ان هذا المسار بدا
من خارجها ومن قوى حتى من داخل التيار
المحافظ لا تنسجم معها في الرؤيه الداخليه
لاداره الدوله والنظام فهي تذهب الى
المعارضه لذلك المنظومه المصالح الداخليه
هي التي تتحكم في المواقف وليس المصلحه
الاستراتيجيه يبدو قد تكون كل التيارات
الاصلاحيون يرحبون بهذا المسار المعتدلون
يرحبون بهذا المسار المحافظون
التقليديون ويرحبون بهذا المسار ولكن
يختلفون على الاليات وعلى المصالح
الداخليه وطريقه توظيف هذه الانجازات او
الانفتاح او السياسات الجديده في المعركه
الداخليه
والسيطره على القرار الداخلي لذلك ما هذه
الصراعات ليس العلاقه مع الخارج العلاقه
المصلحه الداخلي احد المعارك الداخليه
كانت ربما ابعاد او ازاحه
ربما علي شمخان الامين العام للمجلس الامن
القومي في المسجد السيادي دعنا نتابع هذا
التقرير ثم نعود لاستكمال الحوار عنه اذا
في ايران دائما استراتيجيه جديده فرضتها
سياسه الامر الواقع اساسها التحلي
بالمرونه في السياسه الخارجيه لتجاوز اي
عقبات محتمله حيث يحاول مرشد الايراني
ارسال اشارات واضحه مفادها ان طهران
مستعده للتغيير على مستوى اداره ملف
العلاقات الاقليميه للدوله الايرانيه لكن
تغيير هذه المره اخذ منحا مختلفا بالتخلي
عن علي شمخان الذي لعب دورا مهما خلال عشر
سنوات
وحقق انجازات كبيره ابرزها كان انهاء
مرحله طويله من التوتر والتازم سيطرت على
العلاقات بين ايران والسعوديه لكن خدمات
خانه لم تكن لتصمد امام الذي تسعى المؤسسه
العسكريه الايرانيه متمثله بالحرس الثوري
للوصول اليه والمتعلق بمستقبل السلطه
والنظام بعيدا عن الاثقال السياسيه البعض
يرى ايضا ان الرئيس الايراني احد ابرز
المستفيدين من ابعاد او اخراج شمخاني من
المشهد السياسي الا ان هذا التغيير قد لا
يكون بناء على رغبته او طلب منه او قرار
صادر منه بشكل مستقل وانما هو نتيجه تلاقي
المصالح بين الرئيسي والقوه التي مهدت
الارضيه لاتخاذ مثل هذا القرار واستطاعت
الحصول على موافقه مرشد وهو ما سهل اخراجه
من المعادله السياسيه فتوجهات الجيل
الثاني الذي وصل الى قياده
مؤسسه الحرس باتت مختلفه عن سابقاتها
وسطاء الحرس ان ينقل دوره من مستوى الدفاع
وحراسه النظام والدوله الى الشراكه
والنفوذ والسيطره على مفاصل النظام
والدوله فهل كان شابخان يعقبه امام
فهل عقب الشمخان امام طموحات قاده الحرس
على كل حال
نتابع هذا الشريف ثم نعود لاستكمال الحوار
علي شمخاني امين عام المجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي الايراني سابقا لعب دورا كبيرا في
الاتفاق مع السعوديه بواسطه صينيه ينحدر
من منطقه الاهواز من عائله عربيه بدا
حياته من الحرس الثوري الايراني شغل منصب
وزير الدفاع في عهد محمد خاتمي قائد القوه
البحريه للجيش الايراني سابقا كان له دور
بارز في القضاء على الحركات المعارضه شغل
منصب نائب القائد العام لفيلق الحرس
الثوري عضو سابق في المجلس الاستراتيجي
للعلاقات الخارجيه لعب دورا محوريا في
بنيه النظام الايراني ومؤسساته العسكريه
والامنيه والسياسيه
عوده الى ضيف من طهران الدكتور محمد
صادقان برايك من المستفيد من ابعاد او
اخراج شمخاني من المشهد السياسي
انا اعرض هذا التوصيف توصيف الاستبعاد
لعلي شمخاني لان الواقع غير ذلك علي
شوباني هو كان ثمان سنوات امين مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني في عهد الرئيس حسن
الروحاني وبالتالي
عندما فاز الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي من
الطبيعي جدا
ان يتغير من مجلس الامن القومي وبالتالي
ربما وكان هذا مفترض ان يتم تبديل مع
تبديل
وزير الخارجيه ان يتم تبديل او تدوير هذا
المنصب لكن
عقد الجولات جولات الحوار بين طهران
والسعوديه في بغداد هي التي اجلت
يعني تدوير المنصب في امانه مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني حتى
انتهت الى
حياتها في الصين
ووضعت القواعد الاساسيه للعلاقه بين
العلاقه الجديده بين طهران والرياض عند
ذلك تم الاستحقاق وهذا استحقاق كان مفترض
من قبل اكثر من سنه ولذلك لا اعتقد بانه
استبعد لانه هو ذهب الى مكان اعلى هو الان
مستشا هذا ما تقوله يعني السلطات
الايرانيه بانه هذه ليست عمليه استبعاد
لكن هناك من يرى بانها استبعاد والسؤال
السيد حسن فحص انه بعد ان قام شمخاني
بهندسه الاتفاق الايراني السعودي وايضا مع
الامارات ومع العراق والكثير من الملفات
لماذا يتم الاستغناء عنها الا يمكن القول
بانه هذه مكافاه نهايه خدمه له بان ترتاح
بعد ما قدمته لماذا يقال بانه تم ازاحته
او الاستغناء عنه
يعني اتفق مع الاستاذ سفيان على الاليات
الدستوريه او الاداريه في
استبدال
الادميرال شمخانم في موقعه ولكن
السياق حسن روحاني بقي في منصبه 16 سنه في
المجلس الامن القومي يعني هناك استثناءات
لم يستمر اكثر من سنتين او اقل يمكن
سعيد جليله ايضا لم يستمر لم يستمر في كل
دوره
احمد نجاد لذلك
انا لا توجد قاعده ان ما تم هشام خاني لا
لا توجد قاعده لذلك اعتقد ان ما جرى مع
شمخنه هو استبعاد حقيقي لانه
المجلس الامني القومي لغى او الغى دور
الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه ووزاره الخارجيه
والرئاسه الايرانيه
في كل المجريات الاستراتيجيه التي تحدث في
المنطقه يعني كانت كانت شبه مغيبه
ويعطي هذا هامش اكبر لابراهيم هل سيكون هو
المستفيد من هكذا وبرايك المرشد هل بارك
هذه الخطوه او وجه بها
لا اعتقد ان المرشد وجه بها ول لكنه قبل
بها لاعاده تعزيز دور المؤسسه الرسميه
هل من جهه واعطاء
وزاره الخارجيه دورها الطبيعي بان تقوم
ببناء العلاقات وترميم العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وبناء الثقه الدوليه في
العلاقه مع ايران لذلك يعني وحصرها لا شك
ان الان المجلس الامن القومي ووزاره
الخارجيه والسياسات الاستراتيجيه النظام
تبقى حتى الانظار واشراف وتوجيه المرشد
الاعلى
لن تجرؤ الدوله او مؤسسات الدوله على ذهاب
الى سياسات تتعارض مع موقف المرشد ولذلك
تسعى ابراهيم رئيس يسعى لتقديم نفسه كرئيس
ناجح استطاعت بناء علاقات وترميم علاقات
وتحقيق سياسه انفتاح على الدول الجوار
المختلف دول الجوار من اسيا الى القوقاز
الى
هذا صحيح جدا هناك جيل يعني هذا الجيل
القديم او الجيل المخاطره ما الذي وصل
عمره الان اكثر من 65 سنه ربما 70 سنه
ايضا هم كانوا طلاب جامعه في بدايه الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه عام 1980 الان ربما
يعني هناك تجديد في الحرس الثوري في مؤسسه
حرس الثوري وشخصيات القياده في الحرس
الثوري لكن يجب علينا ان نعلم بان هذه
المؤسسه مؤسسه الحرس الثوري والمؤسسه مهمه
في القرار الايراني هذه تتبع سياسه ثابته
توضع اليها سواء كان شمخانيه او علي اكبر
احمد يان هناك سياسه ترسم من قبل مصادر
قرار اخرى في وزاره الخارجيه في مكتب
المرشد في
مجموعه تشخيص مصلحه النظام في البرلمان
الايراني وبالتالي ان يعتقد بان
جيل الاخر او الجيل الجديد الذي جاء في
مؤسسه لكن التيار المحافظ المتشدد في
ايران على مدى اكثر من اربعين عاما حاله
دون تطبيق العلاقات مع مصر مثلا وبالتالي
هؤلاء كانوا هم راس الحربه فيه
وتجديد هذه الدماء قد يغير من الفكر
والمعرض الداخليه التي تتفق معي بعجالها
حتى اسمع راي الاستاذ حسن فحص ايضا
العلاقه مع مصر اعتقد بانها تختلف عن ما
هي مع السعوديه في العلاقه مع مصر الرئيس
الاصلاحي محمد خاتمي زاري ايران زار مصر
القاهره وكان يامل ان تعادل علاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين البلد لكنها لم تحدث وهذا
يعد النقطه الاولى بانه السعوديه
والعلاقات مع السعوديه كانت ربما بوابه
العلاقات الايرانيه يعني ايران كانت تطمح
لاقامه علاقات مع دول الجوار وان تتجاوز
السعوديه وهذا سبب سؤالي في البدايه انه
هل وصلت طهران لقناعه بانه لا يمكن تطبيق
علاقاته مع دول المنطقه دون المرور عبر
الرياض
هذا مهم جدا يعني العلاقه مع الرياض هي
بوابه للدول المجلس التعاون الخليجي لبعض
الدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بوابه الى
الدول العربيه وبالتالي يجب علينا ان نعلم
نحن نتحدث عن المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي
تحتضن الحرمين الشريفين وهي الدوله ليست
صغيره بامكانياتها وحجمها وتاثيرها ودورها
في الجامعه العربيه في المؤتمر الاسلامي
وبالتالي العلاقه مع السعوديه لم تكن
علاقه عاديه وبسيطه
كدوله دوله المملكه العربيه السعوديه ايضا
مهمه جدا في العالمين اخذ كلمه اخيره من
الاستاذ حسن فهد قبل ان نختم هذا الملف
تفضل استاذ حسن
اعتقد ان يعني الانفتاح على مصر او
يعني جاء بعد
الرضا السعودي او
الانفتاح السعوديه على على على
طهران او خاصه انه يعني
او النظام الايراني يتحلى
تعليقا على كلام صديقان يعني
وهناك مقوله لدى الصوفيين الايرانيين او
المتصوف العرفانيين الايرانيين تتعدد
الطرق الى الله بتعدد انفس الخلائق فهناك
طرق دائما لدى الايرانيين للالتفاف على
الازمات
والانفتاح على الاخر
وتسويغ اي معادله جديده
بناء على المصالح الخاصه والاستراتيجيه
للنظام
شكرا جزيلا اعتقد ان الانفتاح الايراني
جدي شكرا جزيلا حسن فحص الكاتب الصحفي كنت
معنا من بغداد والشكر الموصول لضيفي من
طهران دكتور محمد صالح مدير المركز العربي
للدراسات الايرانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات